Brussels wants to inundate us with third
world immigrants mostly from Islamic
countries the Netherlands so the
Netherlands just elected uh girl Gert
Wilders uh he he got 35 seats in the
parliament which means he will create
the next government so he will be the
next prime minister he has been this
guy's been you've probably seen videos
of him for the last probably two decades
he has been one of the most
anti-immigrant
anti-radical Islam politicians in the
well in all of Europe but certainly uh
in amps in Holland uh and he is now
going to be the next prime minister of
the Netherlands take a
look with his aggressive
anti-immigration and anti-islam rhetoric
Hal wiers is set to shake up Dutch
Politics the veteran Firebrand placed
anti-islam policies at the core of his
Party pvv founded in
2004 Wilders has since vowed to stop a
quote Islamic Invasion has held
competitions for cartoons of the Prophet
Muhammad and has been convicted for
insulting
Moroccans Brussels wants to inundate us
with third world immigrants mostly from
Islamic countries it wants to distribute
these immigrants all over the European
Union and that my friends will be a
disaster a ban on mosks Islamic schools
krans and headscarfs from government
buildings are among the proposals on his
people VV Manifesto but he sought to
tone down his anti-islamic rhetoric in
the runup to the election immigration
was a key theme of The Campaign after
the previous government collapsed in a
disagreement over Asylum rules with
Wilders taking a Hardline stance the pvv
has pledged to deport illegal immigrants
and proposes a freeze on
Asylum and the
hope the hope is that people get their
country back that we make sure that the
Netherlands is for the Dutch again that
we will limit the Asylum tsunami and
migration a self-proclaimed fan of
hungary's Victor Oban wers is a staunch
euroskeptic and wants to hold a binding
referendum to leave the EU he has called
for the Netherlands to significantly
reduce its payments to Brussels and to
block the entrance of any new members
unlike many other European leaders
Wilders wants to stop arming Ukraine
saying the Netherlands needs the weapons
to defend
itself you know it's funny before I get
to any of the substantive stuff doesn't
he look like if Matt Gates and Donald
Trump had a baby it would be that guy
like the hair the body the whole thing
anyway look do you think he just became
prime minister because he's racist
because ultimately the people of the
Netherlands are racist or is it because
they have also been overrun and they are
dealing with the same stuff that you're
seeing out of London and New York City
and Paris and elsewhere and they want
borders and that the European Union has
been an abject failure and that they
have had enough with people coming into
their country who don't care about their
country or would gladly upend their
country and they would like their
country back how crazy would that be if
the Netherlands was for the Dutch by the
way the Netherlands the Dutch same
people all the same Holland the
Netherlands the Dutch I know it's
confusing for people all the same people
it's as simple as that guys it really is
as simple as that and of course he will
be called far right and Tommy Robinson
will be called far right and Douglas
Murray will be called far right and
Conor McGregor will be called far right
and I'll be called far right and you'll
be called far right and if we are all
far right then I suspect that the center
is now the right and that is the thing
that probably will save the west and if
it doesn't work then do you know what
will be what will happen on the other
side as our societies really start to
crumble as sectarian violence really
starts to break out in all of the West
and everything else then some really bad
people will become the leaders of these
countries and then some really bad
things will happen and you know what'll
happen then good people ordinary men
will start doing some really bad
things